l'avantagé est de nouveau à la famille
traoré la semaine dernière les
magistrats avaient décidé de confier une
nouvelle expertise médicale à quatre
médecins belges une décision dont
s'était félicité la défense désormais il
s'agit de fouiller un peu plus dans le
passé des gendarmes les juges
d'instruction veulent savoir s'ils
avaient des antécédents judiciaires et
souhaite que des dossiers administratifs
soit constitué le but déterminer s'il
existait ou non un contentieux entre
adama traoré et les trois représentants
des forces de l'ordre
comprendre le jeune homme at il été mise
en cause dans d'autres affaires commis
d'autres délits pour lesquels ces mêmes
gendarmes seraient intervenus d'une
façon ou d'une autre
l'avocat de la famille traoré maître
yassine bouzrou voulait une
reconstitution des faits il faudra
attendre l'issue de la fameuse expertise
médicale dont les conclusions ne sont
pas attendues avant janvier 2021
une décision qui semblerait-il est loin
de lui plaire nous constatons qu'après
quatre années d'inertie et de
manifestations dénonçant le déni de
justice
les juges ont depuis le rassemblement
devant le palais de justice du 2 juin
2020 ordonné 16 actes d'investigation et
une expertise médicale confié à des
médecins étrangers
les avocats des gendarmes défendent eux
la thèse de l'hyperthermie la
température d'adama traoré était de 39
de deux heures après son dessert jour de
grande canicule
il se base également sur les
déclarations d'un témoin chez qui le
jeune homme se serait réfugié maître
bouzrou souhaité aussi que l'enquêté
soit confiée à la brigade criminelle
celle ci restera finalement dans les
mains de l'inspection générale de la
gendarmerie nationale et en attendant
d'éventuels nouveaux rebondissements le
collectif justice pour adama coûte bien
poursuivre ses actions durant cet été
samedi une marche ainsi qu'un festival à
damas en l'honneur du jeune homme seront
organisées à beaumont sur oise au nord
de paris